again let's see if people will trickle
in here
i'll watch and see if people are
watching us out there and hello i want
to welcome anybody who is out there
currently
we have a lot of people apparently
according to youtube already watching
and for good reason because we have
a phenomenal guest today we have none
other than
a very very esteemed colleague
from uh from the eastern seaboard and
this is a man who's been a
inspiration and a remote mentor to me
although he hasn't really
he doesn't get to have any of the blame
for any of the bad things i've done
thanks to his tutelage but uh but i want
to welcome
professor frank wilceck author of a
beautiful question and we'll be talking
about this book but
also his upcoming book called
fundamentals how are you today frank
i'm great and doing very well
in this kind of self-imposed quarantine
in concord massachusetts
yes
a friend from uh from the eastern from
the outskirts of boston shall we say
after uh shelley glashow was on last
week and i
i want to uh then i'm going to be
welcoming your colleague
ray weiss next week so i want to
encourage people to subscribe to the
channel we're getting a lot of great
interviews we had sheldon glashow
i talked to your rival crosstown rival
cameron vapha
two weeks ago and that'll be coming out
soon and then ray weiss and barry bear
so please stay tuned to the into the
impossible
podcast but first we're going to start
with this book a beautiful question
which i found
uh quite beautiful and we were just
remarking before we went live
about the choice of covers i always joke
i always judge books by their covers uh
but
in this case as in many cases uh first
of all this book has two covers it has a
beautiful outer dust jacket which i'm
gonna dispense with
because how much dust do people really
have like flying around their libraries
i've never understood the dust jacket
but i do know that if you don't have a
dust jacket the book is worth a lot less
and here we see a beautiful inner cover
depicting constellations that's my
territory we're going to talk about that
all sorts of fun stuff today with frank
wilceck winner of 2004
uh call recipient 2004 nobel prize and
we're going to talk about uh
that event but first frank i listened to
the audiobook
the audiobook has 260 chapters and i
want to point out to you
that the uh the new testament only has
240 chapters
so i don't know if what
is each page a chapter i guess
each break is each kind of paragraph
they turn into an audio chapter but it
makes it easy to get to you know chapter
200 but i'm gonna ask you so you know
where you are yeah
you didn't design the cover but you came
up with the title can you explain the
title because
if i'm not mistaken it's sort of a
double entendre
as they might say yes the beautiful
question refers to an actual question
which is does the world embody beautiful
ideas
and that was a question that was
constantly in my mind as i planned and
wrote the book
and was i thought a very fertile theme
and then when it came to making a title
i had a different working title which i
don't remember
anymore but then the question grew on me
and
and the possibility of having that
little play on words i thought was uh
too
too good to pass by and beautiful
and it really is a beautiful question
yeah it's a beautiful thing
so the question of whether or not the
universe embodies beautiful ideas
um you know kind of strikes the reader
right off the top
as provocative because it's not even
clear what a question is
what is beautiful about it and and
necessarily
why would the universe have some
teleological purpose to
embody a very human uh notion such as
the notion of beauty so the first thing
i want to start with
is the role of symmetry plays a huge
role in this book
and i want to talk about something in
that you bring up in the book
which is also adorned with quite lovely
gorgeous illustrations
that uh that represent aspects of
symmetry throughout
throughout the universe so to speak and
i want to ask you a question about
um about the the the utility of
of beauty can you use as some suggest
beauty as a guide
in science not only to aesthetically you
know
pleasing endeavors like art but can you
use it as a tool in science
yes well first of all let's go back to
the most primitive kind of science
which also addresses this
teleological issue which is that
when we construct our models of the
world even as children as babies
we face insolvable problems the
information that we gather for instance
on the backs of our retina
is not enough to reconstruct a
three-dimensional world
we have to fill in a lot of stuff and so
we rely
on patterns we rely on mathematical
regularities
usually subconsciously of course but we
have to learn these things as
as as children and
that's that's why to me it's not
a matter of the world being designed to
be beautiful
but rather it's useful to us in
getting into sync with the world and
understanding it and harmonizing with it
and being able to cope with it
that symmetry is a useful guide
and and therefore evolution has made us
think of it as something that's
desirable that we want to have that we
want to interact with
and that's what we feel is beautiful so
that's that's the the the aesthetic
uh version which i kind of turn on its
head it's not a matter of
the world being designed to be beautiful
but us being designed to be in sync with
the world
and finding it beautiful then
then but then uh then a miracle happened
i would say in the 20th century
which is that as we understood
the world the physical world more deeply
we
discovered well let me backtrack a
little
we got into territory where it was very
difficult to do experiments
and when you study
gravity you can look out at planets when
you study
electromagnetism you can do uh
experiments with
macroscopic objects whether you're
looking with
working with magnets or rubbing cat's
fur and so forth
when you uh but when you want to
understand
the inner workings of atoms when you
want to understand
in particular what's going on inside
atomic nuclei which became
the big problem of 20th century physics
in many ways
it's much much much more difficult to do
experiments
and so the traditional
emphasis of uh fundamental
physics and science of gathering a lot
of data
and then from that inferring equations
that describe
the data in a concise way
was not really available anymore or
lost a lot of its power instead what
turned out to be very successful
is to guess equations based on some kind
of
aesthetic principle uh and symmetry
was turns out to be the most important
aesthetic principle
that's successful here uh to guess
equations that are highly symmetric
and then work out their consequences and
see if they can explain phenomena
so it was instead of going from the
phenomena to
uh finding beautiful equations we
guessed beautiful equations
and then uh figured out if they could
possibly describe the world
yeah so and it works yeah it's actually
amazing
quite interesting i'm getting a question
from my friend simon farmer who's asking
how much of the beauty narrative comes
in hindsight you know this this notion
of beauty is only skin deep it makes me
think
you're looking into the past uh you're
looking into the skin
so to speak but and only later do you
find it beautiful
when you were coming up with asymptotic
freedom i i did you look and say
let me find a very beautiful beautiful
idea uh it was that was that what
happened or no
it can't be it must have been that it
was retroactively or retrospective
no no it was much well it's much more
down to earth but that was sort of
lurking in the background
i mean first of all we were looking at
beautiful candidate theory well or at
least not
terribly ugly candidate theories so we
wanted to have
we wanted to use uh quantum field
theories so things which embody general
principles of quantum mechanics and
relativity
uh and then within those theories we
wanted ones that
um had
controllable behavior so you could
actually calculate consequences
and then within that we focused on
theories that ultimately we focused on
theories that
certainly in retrospect but i think even
beforehand i would have said this
are the most beautiful quantum field
theories they
are quantum field theories that have
what's called gauge symmetry
they are they have an enormous amount of
symmetry that
uh random quantum field theories don't
have
and so it was very uh
important to uh
investigate the possibility that you
know maybe those theories do describe
the world
uh if if not we would have learned
something
it would have been a disappointment but
but uh
it turns out that it's not certainly not
obvious at first but if you
work with the theories and listen to
what they're telling you
you learn that indeed they can be used
to describe the world
very very accurately and precisely and
concisely and beautifully
and you know in listening to the book
and reading the book i found
your writing uh very evocative and
almost poetic in
in terms and i'll look up this quote but
there's a famous quote first of all from
dirac
that it's more important that your
equations be beautiful than that they be
correct but he also said something that
uh to the effect i'll look up the exact
quote
something to the effect that uh poets
let me see if i can find this
uh poets direct i think you know the
quote that i'm saying um
poetry i know it roughly okay i'll let
you look it up here it is
in science one tries to tell people in
such a way as to be understood by
everyone
something that no one ever knew before
but in the case of poetry
it's the exact opposite and yet you
quote everybody
from walt whitman to e.e cummings you
have
a phenomenal ability to to kind of go
into the esoteric
right of poet of poetics do you find it
as distasteful as your fellow laureate
uh
uh mr dr paul dorack
no no i i kind of like poetry it's mind
expanding i i
i the sentiment that he expressed and
maybe it's a related but different
quotation
is that uh in in in poetry
uh i'm sorry in physics you try to
express complicated ideas in the
simplest possible way in poetry it's
just the opposite yes
and and of course there's something
to be said about describing things in
different ways
this gets this can be very fruitful to
the most concise description
may not exhaust the possibilities for
relating to or understanding or
interacting with some system especially
as the systems
go from being atoms to human beings or
or flowers in between right there there
are different levels of description and
poetry is
poetry can add for sure yeah and of
course you know feynman
said uh something to the effect that you
know why is it worse
for him to describe jupiter as a giant
ball of methane
than a poet to describe it as if it was
uh you know a poet
using poetic license as if it was a man
right and my point is
is that it it's not either or it can be
both
and and this this is
actually very very closely related to a
deep
philosophical principle which is also a
deep
principle of physics which is
complementarity
which is that you can have different
descriptions of the same object or the
same phenomenon
that each are valid
in their own terms and each answer
important questions
but they answer different questions and
if you try to use one
try to use one description to to address
inappropriate questions it can run out
of steam or actually be wrong
so originally this was applied to
position versus momentum and quantum
mechanics where it's a theorem
but i think it's a much much more
general phenomenon
so for instance it applies to this
question of free will versus determinism
for some purposes it's good to think
that we have free will but for other
purposes
it's uh better and more realistic to
think that
we're largely determined and yeah and
often times we find
complementary approaches you go through
a good deal at the beginning
of the book talking about pythagoras and
you know it's good to see him getting
some citations you know his
his h indexes his h index was suffering
lately but
it's good to have uh wheelchair quoting
his his work but you talk about the
unification the complementarity the
unification
of physical tangible mass being uh
you know unified or coupled to the
notion of pitch or harmony and frequency
you want to talk a little bit more about
that and then we'll get in so we went
from poetics
which is a form of art now we're going
to talk about sound and then we're going
to get into light
and then later we'll get into uh some
sort of ideas that i have
uh come across that i would love to run
by you in terms of time translation
asymmetry
and so forth but you don't get into this
so much in this book but you do in your
next book fundamentals we'll be talking
about that right just a reminder we're
talking to frank wilczak professor frank
welchek winner
co-recipient of the 2004 nobel prize in
physics i ask you
to leave a comment and subscribe and
frank as you know uh it's really bad
nowadays at home we're getting a lot of
carpal tunnel syndrome
so stretch your thumb and click on the
subscribe button
and leave a like for the into the
impossible podcast
that's the only way i get people like
frank to come on the show uh talk to me
about the unification of things like
mass
and and and frequency those are two very
disparate concepts
that i don't think even as a physicist
i'd really grasp
their significance of their
interrelationship
okay so we have to do that in two steps
uh
so first there's a relationship between
energy and frequency this is an
aspect of particle wave duality if you
like that in quantum mechanics we
learned that there are
complementary descriptions of uh of
physical objects
one of which is appropriate to asking
questions about position
and the other of which is appropriate to
answering questions about
momentum or roughly speaking velocity
and similarly we have
descriptions in which we talk about the
energy of things or we talk about the
frequency of things
and to be precise in the case of photons
there's a relationship between those two
concepts
which is that the energy of a photon
is related to its color its frequency
by a very simple mathematical formula e
equals
h nu which was discovered really before
modern quantum mechanics by plank and
einstein
so energy is linearly related to
frequency in quantum mechanics and
that's
a really extraordinary thing because you
think of
uh frequency as of
you know the sound of a note or the
look of a color whereas energy seems to
be something quite different
and yet this profound relationship
exists
so that that's one relationship so e
equals h nu that's one equation to keep
in mind the other biggest thing
to keep in mind is e equals m c squared
that
uh energy can also uh
be related to the mass the energy of a
particle when it's at rest
is proportional to its mass uh and then
if you put those two together
you learn that mass is related to
frequency
so we have uh this
relationship between something you think
of as very
kind of earthy ponderous and something
you think of as dynamic and moving and
and
somehow uh associated with uh radio
waves or
or uh music or quantity but they're
they're
mathematically related yeah and
then let me introduce you to a third
idea because this is a great theme
which is that in quantum chromodynamics
in our theory of the strong interaction
we really reverse e equals m c
squared into m equals e divided by c
squared where we learn that
most of the mass of protons almost all
of it
and neutrons and atomic nuclei in
general
and therefore almost all of our mass as
human beings
is actually not is actually constructed
from energy
the building blocks out of which we
build these things are massless
particles gluons
and very very nearly massless particles
quarks
but they're moving around inside protons
they're very dynamical
so they carry a lot of energy and if you
add up all that energy
and divide by c squared you get the mass
of the proton
so we have this fantastic sort of
movement back and forth between energy
and mass and
frequency and beautiful equations that
require particles to be mass equals zero
and yet constructing a world where
things do have mass
so to me that's one of the very high
points of 20th century
physics well of of of human civilization
really
to understand that that origin of
our very tangible mass in terms of
really ideally beautiful mathematical
concepts
so in terms of beauty and and sort of
mathematics
becoming embodied you quote a lot as we
move from
uh from newton and uh and pythagoras a
little bit more modern into
discussing uh discussing now hertz and
maxwell
you talk about how uh how hertz the
german physicist who proved
experimentally the existence of new
electromagnetic waves
that maxwell had predicted what we now
call radio waves he said of maxwell's
equations
one cannot escape the feeling that these
mathematical formulae
have an independent existence and an
intelligence
of their own that they are wiser than we
are even their discoverers
that we get more out of them than was
originally put into them
you kind of you know built on this with
uh with with david gross
uh back in the 70s and of course frank
uh yang who i'm hoping to get frank on
the podcast
another frank another frank frank yang
cn yang on the podcast he's
he's getting up there in years but uh
but i'm hoping to get him on the podcast
that would be a real treat the yang
mills
that would be remarkable yeah and i'll
let you know maybe you can do a guest
a guest spot when he comes on with uh
with jim simons who's
of course my friend and and uh
benefactor behind my experiment
uh but but at any rate you know what you
guys did is sort of you and
yang and mills built upon maxwell's
equations and actually you know now we
think about you know
qcd as sort of having this power and i
wonder
did you unleash too much power as as
hurt said
is it was it wiser than the discoverers
than you
and david uh and david uh oh yeah
what oh much much wiser than we much
wiser than us
we we certainly didn't anticipate all
the consequences that have flowed
from uh our basic discoveries i mean i i
did realize very early that uh you know
within within a few weeks that this
could be the theory of the strong
interaction and we could
look forward to actually experimentally
uh
checking it and and uh
so that that i already thought well
we'll get a nobel prize for sure out of
that if it works
but uh but but there was much more that
we didn't understand and much more that
we didn't anticipate
so we didn't understand for sure
uh a crucial property of
uh the theory with quarks and gluons
which is how
quarks and gluons are inevitably
confined into more complex objects
so whereas with atoms you can separate
them into nuclei and electrons
with the strong interaction analogs you
can't separate them
into their constituent quarks and gluons
that the equations tell you were there
and that was a very new
and troubling concept to the physics
world that you could have
particles within your equations that you
could never observe
but and and we thought that would be
possible
because the theory is complicated and
it's full of massless particles which
uh have ways of reorganizing themselves
and and uh very singular behavior as you
try to pull them apart but we certainly
couldn't prove it or
calculate it and uh that was kind of a
leap of faith we
we calculated things that we could
calculate but we
left a lot of things open uh
it would be wrong to say that we left
some details open we calculated a few
details and left almost everything open
and then but then that then uh
the applications to uh
the the the experiments that we were
explaining were kind of
uh limited and uh
at that time very imprecise and needed a
lot of interpretation
i certainly didn't anticipate that at
higher energies
uh the underlying structure of the
theory
becomes so much clearer and easier to
understand
then in in high really high energy
events
the quarks and the gluons that are
emitted at very very high energies
kind of leave trails behind like like
the like
uh like jet planes would leave a path
and that makes them easy to see and so
although you can't see the quarks and
gluons themselves you can see those
so-called jets
and check the theory in very great
detail you can also
use the basic theory to
understand the structure of the events
and that's become
the dominant method of very high energy
accelerator physics
you have to understand those things
which are sort of a trillion times more
common
if you're going to find the higgs
particle for instance you have to
understand the
so-called backgrounds very well in the
early days it was very exciting and we
talked about calculus checking qcd and
seeing
if this was the right theory nowadays
it's called
calculating backgrounds but it's the
same it's the same activity in fact it's
much more rigorous now but
but it sounds much less glamorous um
and also i i i sort of anticipated but i
didn't anticipate
how dramatic the consequences would be
that
we could start to study the very early
universe in a rational way
because we had now the dominant
interactions under
control and they got simple
at high energies as opposed to
complicated so
it's actually in many ways easier to
calculate the properties
of matter in very close to the big bang
than it
is say in the center of the earth
we have we have uh much much more
powerful
approximations that that that uh apply
in the in the former case but not the
latter
so opening up the early universe to view
was something
i didn't anticipate right at first but
within a few months i realized that that
would be possible and started working on
it
so i want to get into uh to the aspects
of testing these beautiful ideas
but before i do uh since you brought it
up uh i wasn't going to go here but you
brought up this little
medallion you mentioned the the nobel
prize so now it's fair game now i could
mention it and uh my feelings on the
nobel prize are
well known as you can tell by the rumor
well i could see it's in you it's
it's in your background you must be
aware yes oscar wilde said a boy must
hustle his own books
uh my my polemic but i do wanna say uh
i've always been curious since you are a
legendary person i mean you're extremely
modest you're you're
basically free of ego as i can tell i
mean i've talked to betsy
on twitter
you discovered these uh you know
asymptotic freedom with david dear
advisor
1973 and it took you know 30 years
almost uh 31 years uh before
you were rewarded with the nobel prize
everybody on god's green earth knew
uh you guys deserved what was that
period like and it wasn't like you're
waiting for verification i mean all
these things are verified almost
immediately
after the jets and they became a tool as
you just mentioned
not only for investigating the
substructure of hadrons but but for the
early universe as well
on a personal level frank how did it
feel this waiting
31 years for the inevitable uh to occur
well it was annoying you know and
[Laughter]
if you think about uh my the half-life
uh okay so we the clock starts ticking
and i'm 21 years old or something and
then
uh if if if it doesn't happen for 30
years and then it doesn't happen for
another 30 years
it's getting it's getting a little iffy
right so
uh so that that that was that was one
way of thinking about it and
but on the other hand uh i
realized well really that
uh i think that i now i appreciate
that living through it was difficult
frankly really was difficult
uh but uh
in retrospect i
learned some things and i also realized
some things that that make it
uh that i should have that would have
eased the pain so to speak
which is first of all that the the nobel
committee
is very very conservative they're very
protective
of the reputation of of alfred nobel and
the prize
so they really uh want
things that have somehow or
at least in most almost all cases
historically
have wanted developments that have
empirical verification
and that won't turn out to be wrong
and that would be embarrassing uh
and in our case no comment no comment
theory
in in our in our case since the theory
made such precise predictions
that meant it could be wrong it could it
could be proved quantitatively wrong or
missing something major uh i think most
theorists
most theorists who are competent to
judge by
certainly by the the the
late 70s early 80s or so had a lot of
faith in the theory
but experiments were coming up with the
lar
with lep the big electron positron
collider which would do much
more precise tests and so
that they you could wait on that and
and they did and then uh
um the other aspect is that
uh our work built on work of others in a
in a major way
so on the experimental work of uh
friedman kendall and taylor especially
uh at at slack where they discovered the
so-called scaling phenomena
that was really the phenomenon that we
aimed at in our initial investigations
that was the kind of experimental
fact about quarks that we wanted to
understand
uh so until they got the nobel prize it
would have been very anomalous for us to
get a nobel prize
and then on the theoretical side uh we
were also
building on especially the work of it
hooft and veltman
who sort of showed how you could do
uh some powerful kinds of calculations
in the kinds of
tricky theories that we wound up using
and so i didn't think we would so they
had to come first also
so there's an ordering so the reason it
took so long for us
is that it took so long for them i think
yeah so um let's get back to the
uh to the to the impersonal now you talk
in the book a lot about
unification about um complementarity
and i get a lot of emails as i'm sure
you do
you probably get these on steroids
although i had uh i had adam reese on
the show over the summer and and i said
you know i get
all these emails you know basically once
a day and it says you know professor
keating i've got a new theory of
everything
um i can't do the math but if you help
me do the math uh i'll share my nobel
prize with you
and uh and i say and adam and adam
leaned in and he said how do you think i
got my nobel prize
but it's always you know people are
always saying you know einstein was
wrong and and i wonder i i talked to
barry barish and that interview will air
next week or so i believe uh so please
everybody subscribe to the into the
impossible podcast if you want to hear
more great interviews
but uh uh returning to the nobel prize
for just one last moment
uh barry told me that he always suffered
from imposter syndrome his whole life
and none more so
than when he went to collect his nobel
check and sign this
log book which must have your name in it
and he saw not only your name but he saw
this guy's name albert einstein
and it gave him tremendous imposter
syndrome do you ever feel
impostor syndrome uh especially or the
nagging period of
three decades between discovery and and
the award
no okay i really don't because
and there's a reason for it which is
very concrete uh
when i well or said i got over in
imposter syndrome when i went to college
i guess or maybe even before because
i i went i was in the new york city
school system
and at that time we had a lot of tests
we had a lot of
uh grading and
tracking they call it uh and
i got a lot of encouragement from that
process so
you know i i knew i had done very very
well on objective measures of
uh intelligence and so forth
so i didn't feel like i never felt like
an imposter and then you know
even when i went to the university of
chicago things were very easy for me
i wish i had worked harder in many ways
i wish things didn't
hadn't come so easily when i got to
princeton things didn't start off by
coming so easily
it was kind of a rough transition but uh
but no i i i unfortunately
a consequence of early success is that
you get confidence and i've got that's
extremely important
uh to a research scientist that
confidence is
is pure gold i mean because it allows
you to think
uh of diff think in different ways to
not
worry about what other people think so
much and
uh to think that you could you know to
take on big problems because you
think that you have a chance of doing
better than other people have done on
them yeah
conversely do you feel like afterwards
after winning it that you had some
superpower i mean it's rumored that your
fellow laureate t.s eliot
said something to the effect that the
nobel prize is a ticket to one's own
funeral
for no one has done anything after he
won it but you're a counter
example to that uh but uh do you feel
the converse effect the
anti-imposter syndrome takes over once
you actually do receive the nobel prize
in terms of confidence well since i did
have so long to think about it i did
think about
the afterlife so to speak and i looked
around and i
you know i there are many people i
admire that had won nobel prizes and i
looked at their lives after the nobel
prize and
some had done better than others and
to me the uh the success stories
like feynman like yang like td lee are
people who uh kind of took it in stride
and and went on writing papers
whereas there are some other people i
won't name that kind of got intimidated
by the prize they thought that
nothing they could do afterward would
live up to what they had done before
or to the prestige of the prize and
i wanted to be like the first group not
the second group
so sort of i planned right away
that after getting the prize i would
write some papers that might be mediocre
just to have done it just to break the
ice
and and that's what i did and i kept
working and well
i've been fortunate in that a lot of the
ideas
that i had early in my career i've had a
very big afterlife
like anions and axions
and so you know
i can build on that it's they're still
at the frontiers of
of research but also i've fortunately my
style has always been to uh
do something uh try to make a a basic
contribution and then to move on and do
something else
i'm not someone who sticks in the same
place and digs deeper and deeper i
move from one thing to another and
with that style you're often going to
fail so i got used to failure
also and and so uh
so uh i wasn't afraid of failure either
before or after the nobel prize
so i i didn't i didn't get intimidated
by it no
so now about some of the work you've
done since
uh since then including your recent work
on a unification of forces uh first i
want to take a break to just to
recognize our guest we're talking
to uh professor frank wilcheck about uh
his
book uh a beautiful question which is
upside down which is
it's too bad it's not perfectly
symmetrical or else i would have been
able to pull that off
this is a beautiful book and i learned a
tremendous amount i got great insight as
you will
into what it's like to be a physicist
and to think about
the existential questions but to do so
with an artist's eye
and maybe a musician's ear and whatever
other
tactic a sculptor's fingers or whatever
well i think
very important is a historic historic uh
historian's appreciation of human
endeavor i really enjoy learning about
the history of ideas yeah
and you go way back as we said to uh
pythagoras to aristarchus you know
boosting their h indices
as we go the thing
uh well to think about how these greek
minds
wrestled with difficult problems and the
paths that they went down that we now
know were
mistaken but but seemed why did they
seem plausible how did they
explore them you can i i've learned a
lot and been very inspired by
studying the history of ideas yeah and
and i think that comes through
in this book and you talk a lot about uh
isaac newton
not only for his role along with um
maxwell
himself james clerk maxwell who if i'm
not mistaken is your
is your role model as a physicist as
your kind of favorite physicist in
history
uh as you are to probably millions of
people around the world frank but i want
to say
about newton what what really is amazing
about newton
and certainly uh you know later later
people like faraday etc
was that they had this deep uh love of
solving puzzles
and uh it's it's uh reputed that they
would think about these things really
without ceasing einstein as well this
toy that uh
anthony z talks about uh is kind of his
most
magical thing was finding a getting a
compass from his dad
uh i want to talk about uh about
experiment because i'm an
experimentalist um you know which i
always joke you know there's a joke what
do you call someone who hangs out with
musicians
you call him a drummer what do you call
someone who hangs out with physicist you
call him an experimentalist
i can say that you can't say that uh but
i get
i get emails every day about um you know
professor keating as i said einstein was
wrong
not only is going to the nobel prize but
going to
uh this notion that uh that we somehow
want to outdo einstein that we want to
do what einstein didn't do
maybe as a favor to the old man or maybe
as to vindicate him
um you know he certainly didn't do as
much that was um
really held in high esteem after he did
win the nobel prize but getting
to his dream of a so-called theory of
everything i've been talking to roger
penrose
i talked to lenny suskind i talked to
kamran vaffa
and many others luckily i'm very blessed
to have them as members oh and reminder
out there
exercise your fingers don't get carpal
tunnel syndrome press the subscribe
button the like button we can get more
uh time with frank wilcheck uh if he's
if he's uh he is such a gracious person
he has not only agreed to come on today
but to time translate and use that
symmetry to next month
in january he'll be back on to talk
about his new book fundamentals that's a
phenomenal book as well anyway getting
back to einstein and
unification of forces there is uh the
common thread that runs through almost
all these emails and and uh topics that
i've been talking about with people like
penrose etc
this notion that we need a theory of
everything because we don't understand
to how to unify gravity with quantum
mechanics i want to uh just
push back on that notion as an
experimentalist
i said this to roger to his face i'm not
speaking out of school i said
no one's ever going to go into a
singularity i mean lenny talks about
that in his book
you can't visualize a singularity and uh
and people like roger in his book uh
cycles of time which we talked about
last month right after he won the nobel
was announced to be the nobel prize
recipient
co-recipient we talked about his model
for conformal cyclic cosmology
which does away with the initial
singularity at which point people
were using as motivation for a theory of
quantum gravity i'm going to talk to you
later
about your paper with lawrence krauss
about inflation and
unification of forces but first why do
we need a theory of
quantum gravity when we can't know for
sure if there was an initial singularity
and two we can't access what occurs at
the
uh core of a black hole and three we
have no example we have no example in
nature
of an infinite quantity smoothly
transitioning
uh to a finite quantity so why do we
need to unify
uh gravity with quantum mechanics at all
like well at a practical level uh
we probably don't they i mean
you know i'm sure as a practicing
astrophysicist
that in astrophysics people deal with
situations where gravity
and quantum mechanics are both important
at the same time
every day that's that's that's the world
and it's
it's as common as dust that you have
gravity and
quantum mechanics working in harmony to
uh describe
the natural world in in great detail
with great accuracy
but uh when you push things really
really hard when
when you try to calculate tiny uh
corrections due to quantum fluctuations
of gravity
uh you find that uh
our existing theoretical apparatus
doesn't give any
sensible answer and you would like to
understand
situations where things do get very
extreme like at the center of black
holes
but maybe like the very early very very
very early universe
and and that so that's a kind of
quasi-practical application
and then there's finally the simplest
reason that you want to do it is that
gravity is there and quantum mechanics
is there and you want to have a
consistent theory that includes both
so uh it may or may not be important for
any
practical or even theoretical problem
uh but but it's it's a challenge it's an
intellectual challenge if you like
to uh and it might have unexpected
consequences
in fact i think an uh a quasi-unexpected
but
potentially important uh consequence
is that we have a model
called inflation that seems to explain a
lot about
uh cosmology as you know
uh but its foundation in theory
is very very uh shaky i would say
uh and and uh
the the existing models of inflation are
sort of a counter example to beauty and
physics i would say they're really super
ugly
and don't really fit experiment very
cleanly and
uh so there's something missing in our
understanding of early universe
cosmology and it's quite
possible in my mind that understanding
quantum gravity better
will address that cluster of real
questions that are that are
connected to actual observations um
so okay i think that answers your
question
yes yeah actually let's go to
um what what kind of is a as an allied
question a concomitant question
uh but before we do that we just
received a chat
from a uh very munificent and generous
listener who is paying us ten dollars
not
not you frank i'm sorry uh but it also
goes to my my 529 college savings plan
for my kids and pete is asking
the following question he is asking
wouldn't a more complete understanding
of gravity
potentially enable us to do more to
manipulate gravity
that's provocative well
it's conceivable of course until we have
the understanding
we don't know what we can do with it but
it seems far-fetched to me
uh let me let me tell you why
in in very concrete terms so
consider the ligo experiment which in
recent years
succeeded in detecting gravitational
waves
they had to work very very hard to
be able to observe any effect they had
to develop new methods
of keeping things from shaking they had
to make
innovations in laser technology they
had to build things on a grand scale the
apparatus are
four miles long and you have to have
several of them all around the world
and yeah so so it's a it's a very very
challenging enterprise
and you're looking for effects where uh
the distortions produced in space-time
by uh
gravitational waves are smaller than the
radius of a nucleus by a considerable
factor
so it's it's not so
that so so that's that's manipulating
gravity or manipulating space time
and what did it take to do that tiny
effect it takes
two gigantic black holes colliding
and just in the last moments of the most
violent collision
they produce this tiny tiny signal so
the point is simply that gravity is a
very very weak force
fundamentally and so
i think the prospects of doing
engineering with it
at a quant by by better understanding of
the quantum mechanics of gravity
is very very far-fetched now time may
prove me wrong but but i
i doubt it well they laughed at uh at
john newhouse and some
right nobody knows who that is because
nobody he was wrong but i just want to
give a little tease i can't resist it so
people in the 1700s looked at lightning
and they would have said oh we can never
you know approach the power the fearsome
power of the electron or whatever they
would have called it but then
allegedly uh none other than my hero
michael faraday
said uh when allegedly i guess when
asked by william gladstone the british
prime minister of
minis british minister of finance back
then about the practical value of
electricity faraday said
one day sir you may tax it uh that's
right
yeah yeah so and i built tax ground
that's that's
that's or or that's a warning
yeah that's a warning but but on the
other hand
now we understand things much better and
much more completely
so yes the fact the idea that we're
missing something enormous that could be
used in engineering
is is a lot more challenging and
uh what's with the other thing i was
going to say
never mind that's enough yeah so i want
to get to this and i have a lot of
comments from people
in the audience sometimes i do a poll
and i say you know leave a comment
if you have a theory of everything and
then
give a thumbs up if you've heard about a
theory of everything
recently so let's uh let's do that uh
but i want to talk about your paper
this is from 2014 soon after my team and
i
released the bicep two results you and
lawrence krauss wrote a paper from b
modes
to quantum gravity and unification of
forces the reason i want to go here
is that i feel it's very important for
scientists
if they have a theory of everything to
uh to
pursue all existing avenues of data and
you just gave an example
of which was meant to be kind of um
illustrative of how hard it is to do
experiments in gravity but what if i
told you yeah you know most of the time
i get these theories of everything
someone like garrett lisey or my friend
eric weinstein who may join
us at the end of the show the question
of well i want to test this theory but
it relies on such high energy phenomena
that we will need a bigger particle
accelerator and i always say
like imagine if you wanted to test
gravity and you said i i want a bigger
particle accelerator i'd say
well i how about this i have a neutron
star collider
will that do i'll take two neutron stars
at 99.9 percent the speed of light i'll
crash them together would that do
in other words why aren't people as
willing as you were to look at the low
energy limits of different phenomena as
you said
you know uh asymptotic freedom was sort
of
confirmed not through direct observation
of quarks but through the jet processes
that i mean that was very very hard to
do but it wasn't as hard
as finding the higgs right
oh well it made finding the hicks
conceivable actually but
uh the
well that's an example where you know i
i think we would have been justified in
saying that
we need higher energy accelerators to
really test the theory and that that
worked
uh in the case of quantum gravity though
the we can estimate
what the required energies are and
they're just not going to be available
uh anytime soon maybe never
you know you need you would need
accelerators the size of the
solar system and an energy budget which
is way beyond human energy consumption
so
uh don't hold your breath on that one
now but on the other hand if you have a
bright idea
you might be able to see consequences of
quantum gravity
at low energies and uh that this work i
did with lawrence was an example of that
where
well it's not it's using the early
universe as an accelerator yeah
so you could find relics left for over
from the early universe
you get to also look at signals from
colliding black holes as i mentioned or
or black or now uh black holes and
neutron stars
so there are there is data out there and
in general i have very little sympathy
for theoretical physicists who say
oh my theory is great but you can't test
it
that's a failure that's that's not an
excuse that's just a failure
and okay in a more constructive vein
i've been thinking recently
about uh the quantum nature of
gravitational radiation
it's usually it has been treated as a
classical field
that rattles around the things in ligo
in a certain way based on classical
mechanics basically
but in reality the black holes produce a
quantum everything is quantum
and the black holes create a quantum
field of radiation
and they're very different i'm fine i'm
discovering
and uh i hope there'll be observable uh
consequences from that that won't
require
gigantic new accelerators other than the
black holes
yeah we uh experimentalists are a greedy
bunch we want future circular colliders
we want
international linear colliders we want
uh ligos in space
uh but i want yeah to get back to that
paper that you wrote after bicep
uh two results came out um as you just
mentioned you know
the phenomena of gravitational waves
leaving a b mode imprint in the
polarization of the microwave background
is a based on classical perturbations
not quantum mechanics so what would be a
definitive
early universe test of the quantum
nature
of gravity that is the graviton
so-called graviton
well in that paper we argued that uh
observation of uh
gravitational waves from the early
universe that uh
had basically a thermal character
was a strong indication of the quantum
nature of gravity
uh in the same way that observations
about the black body radiation
led uh plank and einstein to propose
quantum mechanics in the first place
so there's an h bar that appears in the
equations and that's
pretty sure a sign of quantum mechanics
uh
but there i'm still hopeful that there
would be more
more encompassing implications maybe new
models for how to produce the phenomena
that we
currently ascribe to inflation maybe
some
heterodox version of inflation that's
grown driven by gravity itself rather
than some
ad hoc inflatant field uh made
uh
i guess what was the question again i
just just got carried away
what is a fundamental when i think of
quantum mechanics i think of
you know spooky action at a distance
number one i think about
uh you know electron double slit
experiments
what is the analogous because i i agree
with you i don't think we could do an
experiment on gravitons the way we do
with photons but
what conceivable test of early universe
quantum gravity again my theory is not
my theory
my contention is we don't know if my
friend paul steinhardt is right or if
sir roger penrose is right uh there is
no initial singularity and even stephen
hawking you know had the no boundary
uh proposals etc so um what and it's
usually touted
that we need a theory of quantum gravity
because we know the universe had a
singularity
actually we don't and so i would like to
know if there was any way to show that
the universe had a singular i think what
we
no we need a theory of the early
universe that's sufficiently concrete
that you can calculate observable
consequences of it
and we know what we have to calculate
we or certainly some things that should
be calculated that presently are not
those include the amplitude of the
fluctuations
uh the nature of the spectrum are they
non-gaussian
it would be nice to make some
predictions for a change instead
are the is there a significant
gravitational wave background
what is it what's its amplitude and so
forth and there are many many things
that uh
observers like you are are gathering
uh information about and
wouldn't it be nice if the theory
predicted some of those things
yeah or even postdick did something it's
not that there's no material
it's that the theorists have failed to
produce a theory
so far that's so you don't
you can't blame the universe you you you
face it guys you failed
i failed people well hope abounds you
know because einstein
provides a lovely target and a lovely
uh kind of story and i think as you know
stories are
very important to tell a good story even
in uh even in physics but
getting to this point you make the case
in the book uh
uh in the book and of course we're
talking with frank wilcheck winner of
the co-recipient of the 2004
nobel prize uh in physics along with
politzer and
gross and this question we talked a
little bit about the nobel prize and
what it felt to wait for 30 years what
it felt like
on a personal level but during that time
you were making tremendous contributions
and uh and some of those contributions
uh uh rely on things that may best be
seen
uh in the in the universe i'm speaking
about the cp
problem i'm speaking about axions and
these are
probably the hottest topic i've been i
did a plot recently
of axions as a as a topic in in
cosmo and it's you got the hockey stick
going you know al gore
al gore fellow nobel prize winner is
going to do a video
with him on an elevator with axion
citations going up to the moon
uh but the but the point i'm trying to
make is that that's another example of
low energy limit of a potentially high
energy phenomena so
do you want to say of all these things
that you've created first of all i can't
resist because how often do i get the
chat with you
uh you know of all these kinds of things
which would you most like to see
uh confirmed or if you're i think as you
are intellectually honest maybe
disproven uh in the remaining
80 years of your life hopefully
uh well i think i think clearly axions
are the biggest deal
uh because they are as you know they're
a leading and perhaps as you were
hinting now the leading candidate to
provide the dark matter of the universe
they have all the right properties
and i've been cheerleading but also
participating in the attempt to design
antennas you know modified antennas
suited to axions
that will definitively observe that
background so it's not dark anymore
right so we can we can see not only that
it gravitates but also does the other
things that particles
ought to do although very feebly uh
so so that's yeah that's that's great
and and by the way you you quoted hertz
recently
i feel very much that way about uh
axions it's
it's a beautiful extension of
uh this the standard model uh i think
it's fair to say that the
people who invented the theory in some
sense peche and quinn didn't realize
it's
didn't realize its potential they didn't
realize it had axions for evidence right
and much less that axions play such an
important role in cosmology but
it's there i mean you know it comes
right out of the equations
uh when they're when you think about
them carefully and
uh and then there's going to be there's
been a wonderful
creative activity in trying to design
the antennas and
we'll see if if we if if
they're out there it's just now in
recent years getting to the point
where the antennas are getting
sufficiently sensitive that they have a
chance
to actually observe it so it's very
exciting but nerve-wracking
so um before we turn if you've got a few
more minutes before we turn to a couple
more questions from the audience i
wanted to
uh just see if you'll indulge me in your
book you talk a lot about
uh about religion i joked at the very
beginning we spoke
how your book in audio form which i
listened to in addition to reading it
i have the audiobook version of it and
it has 220 chapters in the audiobook
versus the video or versus the new
testament which has 260 chapters
uh and you talk a lot about this
character in the new testament
uh called doubting thomas and i want to
ask you
uh and maybe just to recap that and
maybe even your connection to
uh to i understand you're a catholic but
not in
good standing perhaps or not practicing
catholic you call yourself an
ignorant a very very lapsed catholic you
call yourself
uh an agnostic and i wonder you know
what do you see
similarities between sort of the faith
that it takes to pursue
a scientific idea that you believe is
beautiful
ecumenical or simple economical
and to keep that sort of faith um in the
face of perhaps overwhelming odds
but is there anything about religion or
you know
not in practicing theological sense but
are there any
kind of fruitful interchanges that can
be had
from from questions of faith as a
physicist
i'm not sure i would call it faith but
one thing
that got deeply imprinted on me as a
result
of my religious training as a
you know as a young adult really really
i i
turned away from it as in my early
teenage years so we're talking about
very early but very formative influences
and that the thing i took away from it
permanently i think and is really deeply
embedded
is the idea that the world embodies
secret meanings
that you know the surface appearance of
things is not
the real story that is there's something
else going on
that's uh in the case of religion is
mostly symbolic
or sort of from working out of a moral
scheme
but in science you take it as it comes
you take you
you go out and and learn about what god
is by studying his works
that so that's the attitude i have
and um the
and i don't think faith is no i mean
it's not a matter of faith i would say
it's a matter of
what i call radical conservatism which
is
you have an idea you work out its
consequences
as hard as you can uh because you want
to know if it's correct or not
and if if it is correct you've learned
something very exciting if it's not
correct you've also learned something
useful that you should uh
but vague thinking never gets you
anywhere so
so that so it's so that's a kind of
attitude uh
that i
has something in common with religion
where you try to understand everything
in terms of god
but it's it's i'd say it's a tenuous
relationship
uh so so it's not faith i wouldn't call
it faith i'd call it kind of a working
principle of
uh pushing pushing and uh and
but also of uh uh
it's not a mat uh of appreciating
to to take to to to me
uh okay when i was when i was a
a very young adult as i mentioned uh
until i got disillusioned i got enormous
uh satisfaction about thinking that the
world had
deeper meanings that there was a part of
a big picture that you could be a saint
and so
uh that
and and merge with god or something but
uh
no
and of course unfortunately you know i i
can't believe in that stuff anymore
it just doesn't hold together as as as
i've learned more about
how the world actually works uh but the
way the world actually works is
incredibly beautiful in its own way
incredibly beautiful and i'm happy to be
a part of it you know and happy to be
able to appreciate so much
and learn more and more it's fitting uh
for an author of a book about uh
so-called beautiful questions
that uh that you'd answer that uh in
that way uh okay we're gonna come to the
to the end soon but not before we take
one more
super chat i can't resist the super
chats they put
bread on the table no they don't do that
but
uh they're very much appreciated this
one's from jody geiger i wonder if he's
related to the famous geiger
geiger martin and uh and the man the
only man i think who's a physicist nobel
prize winner
on a piece of legal tender do you know
who that is by the way uh frank
nobel laureate who's on a piece of legal
currency not in america hint
i i don't know for sure i thought maybe
rutherford was in bad news
that's right okay yes rutherford
absolutely very good that was trivia
that you got
anyway going back to geiger maybe he's
related to jody let me know if you're
related to
geiger geiger martin anyway he asked i
have a peer-reviewed published
theory of everything with 20 plus
measured and verified predictions in the
laboratory such as quantum gravity
but this no network went unnoticed for
years so he's asking you
for suggestions how should he proceed he
says it's reviewed peer-reviewed and
published i don't know where
i don't know what experiments that
verify quantum gravity is talking about
but i get this a lot how do we proceed
with a novel theory of everything what
would you recommend
to somebody frank
i would recommend
that uh you take a small part of the
theory
that people can understand independently
if that's possible and uh and
uh if you have a clear prediction uh
write that up
and you know write it so that it follows
from the minimal hypotheses
so that people don't have to work very
hard to understand
a complicated theory in order to uh
understand anything at all
uh and then submit it to regular
journals or
post it on the archive where it can get
the attention of
of people who were in a position to
judge great
and the last question from the audience
that i'll take in the interest of time
comes from someone named zolo
uh does girdle's incompleteness theorem
have any implications for physics
and uh i'll do another uh separate
question in his second topic but
um i always find that you know
physicists have a sense of math envy
in that at least in math we know the
limits of what can or can't be proven
uh self-consistently but no such thing
exists in physics and people usually say
carl popper said
falsification um is there an analog to
girdles
incompleteness theorem in your opinion
for physics
not really uh gurdo's theorem has very
much to do with
well in a limited sense which i'll come
to girdle's theorem
has very much to do with the properties
of formal axiomatic
systems and physics is not that
now maybe there are long-term
aspirations to turn physics into that
and we're nowhere close to doing it at
present but
if we got there then uh ideas around
godrill's theorem would become relevant
very good okay so i'm gonna ask you uh
my own questions that i ask all my
listeners oh my
listeners all my guests on the into the
impossible podcast
uh hopefully you'll enjoy these so
normally
when i have on say like a child
psychologist i say now it's time for the
final three questions
first can you provide a quantum theory
of gravity that's self-consistent
and the child psychology give me five
minutes
uh but now i'm going to ask you because
you've already you know worked on that
um
i want to ask you i uh there's a concept
in
my religion which is judaism of what's
called an ethical will
and it's uh it's what you want to leave
to the future to benefit humanity and
actually alfred nobel
uh who you're well acquainted with had
an ethical component in his material
will which was to make
humanity for the betterment of all
mankind
i want to ask you what aspect or wisdom
would you most want to leave for future
generations as a so-called
inheritance an ethical will of wisdom
perhaps for the future
well i think that's what we'll discuss
in our next podcast okay
because this is very much the kind of
question that i take up in the new book
oh awesome i cannot wait
we're talking about uh frank's next book
as uh is coming out in january
on uh january uh 12th he'll be on the
show january 11th let me know if you
want me to have them back
live like this or we could do a recorded
one but this is called fundamentals 10
keys to reality i'm going to put a link
to purchase the book
in the show notes so uh frank can uh you
can get a head start
in advance of our podcast on january
11th okay
let's get back to my other question that
i ask people maybe this too
will be covered in fundamentals uh but
this is uh
related to the namesake of this show is
sir arthur c clarke
uh and i am the co-director of the
arthur c clarke center for human
imagination i think i've mentioned that
to you once or twice i invited you to
come when the pandemic is over you'll
come and
we'll do an event around you and your
wonderful books but um there's a scene
in the movie 2001 a space odyssey based
on arthur's books
and a series of books and it shows these
primates
on the plains of africa and they're
playing around with this monolith that
they discover
and then later they discover it on the
surface of the moon and yesterday i
talked to
astronaut jessica meir about this about
her experiences
and she said she gets like ptsd thinking
about the hal
spacecraft when she was on the iss but
anyway i want to ask you frank
uh the monolith in 2001 is like a time
capsule
what would you put on a time capsule if
you knew
it would last for perhaps millions of
years into the future what what
summary of of of nature would you
perhaps put in there
well we have the equations of the
standard model that
that are really that are perfect for
that purpose because they can be
precipitated very precisely
uh and concisely in a computer program
so we could
we could certainly write such a program
and
it would be much shorter than the
operating system
of your computer
certainly much shorter than word
[Laughter]
the uh uh and
i i put in axions as a plausible
extension of the standard one
and i put in my new book
which form would you put it on cd-rom
what
what's gonna what's gonna last uh well
you know i uh it's it's very
i mean technology and science have
changed so much
in the last hundred years it's really
nuts in my opinion to think about
what what would be interesting to
the humans or cyborgs or
inheritors of human intelligence that
would be looking at these things even
thousands of years into the future
so uh i guess i'll i'll leave it at that
okay
that's the best answer yeah i'm just
afraid i'll put it on a usb
stick and they we only have usbc we
don't have usb a
okay lastly of course i would also i
should say i don't want to
you know don't want to uh uh
belittle the achievements of
observational astronomers of course
independent of how the world works we
also have
a lot of information about what the
world is
and was and we'd want to have a nice
summary of that as well
that's right yes and that will hopefully
be uh contained in our next podcast we
do that in a couple weeks the last
question i have for frank
uh is also uh kind of related to sir
arthur c clarke who said as you quote in
the book
i'm talking about your current your
previous book a beautiful question which
i
devoured over the last 187 hours of
listening to it on audio
uh but the uh the quote comes from sir
arthur c clarke
one of them is uh relates to his three
laws and his first law
is that for any any sufficiently
advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic you
quote that in your book
the second law which is a little bit
less well-known is for every
expert there's an equal and opposite
expert
i find that to be true and then the
third law
is uh is where we get the name of this
podcast it's
he said the only way of determining the
limits of the possible
is to venture a little way past them
into the impossible and that's the name
of this podcast
i want to ask you what mysterious aspect
of life
perplexed you as a 20 year old or a 30
year old when you were coming up with
these
soon to be or not soon to be but future
nobel worthy things perhaps
um was perplexing mysterious maybe fear
inducing
but now makes sense through the lens of
looking backwards in time so
essentially advice to your former self
what would you tell a 20 year old frank
uh wheelchair
uh
i tell him to
focus more on the basic aspects of
quantum theory
when i early in my career i
had a kind of snobbish attitude about
people who
worried about the foundations of quantum
mechanics i said
i mean come on we use the theory all the
time very successfully and there's not
that the interesting thing is to apply
it in complicated circumstances not not
to understand
uh the basics but but in recent years
it's really become clear
that uh the theory is so deep
and has so much potential that's
been untapped for information processing
and new kinds of uh sensitive detectors
and new ways of understanding the world
that uh it would have been better to get
earlier into the issues of
understanding really very very basic
questions and not to turn up my nose at
it and
sort of brush it off very good uh we
have one more guest
question that's going to come in from uh
from actually live by skype we'll see if
we can get him on this is eric weinstein
who's a friend of the show
who runs his own podcast called the
portal podcast
uh let's see if eric can be patched in
somehow
eric do you hear us
i see his name yeah i see his name but i
don't see him let's see
if he is available i will check to see
there's technical difficulties let's see
if this will come up this is always
challenging oh i think he might be
popping in
there he is let's see i hear eric eric
how do you read us i can i can see you
okay we cannot see you we i can hear you
now
but not to see you it's frank it's been
years good to see you it's very
nice to not see you but to hear you
anyway
this is a great thrill and there are
issues that i've wanted to talk to you
about for some time particularly
with
sorry eric you dropped out you left
an extremely uh provocative comment in
the book which you
pardoned me it's a little hard to hear
you you're you're breaking up a little
bit eric what was it
what's your question maybe here we go oh
there we go now i see you at least
okay very good so can you hear me now
yes yes so i wanted to ask you about a
question from your last book which you
uh tantalizingly drop um
in a provocative fashion and then
deliberately don't follow up
which i thought was a great uh literary
move which is that you
you talk about the so10 theory
uh of uni grand unification so three out
of four forces
and then you say i note that this is uh
the same representation of spin 10 that
is the spinner representation
as the portion that uh
connects to the space time which is the
space-time spinner representation
yeah and then you say whether this is a
coincidence
or an indication of something deeper uh
is not known or something like this and
then you run away
well in my private notebooks i've tried
to
follow up on that uh
and not only in my private notebooks i i
mean i've thought about
models where you extend the spinner
symmetry to explain why there are
families
uh and i will but
that that doesn't bring in space time
but they're also
attempts to bring space-time spinners
and internal space simmer
spinners together i never published any
of that because it didn't
work to my satisfaction but
it's still it's still an interesting
program and maybe somebody would have
better ideas about it
i mean it's a remarkable mathematical
coincidence that these
same structures emerge in such different
contexts
and i don't know i have i have this
sneaking suspicion that it's like
the equivalence principle it's something
that everybody knows that points to
something very deep
but i haven't been able to get that deep
and get it out well you should know that
i spend my every waking moment
trying to make that cryptic comment go
down in history is one of the most
important
but you also probably know that um
the number 10 doesn't get a lot of
attention
when you talk about the so-10 grand
unified model because
what what that 10 that group of
symmetries of 10-dimensional space
is doing for the model is not happening
in the 10-dimensional incarnation of the
group it's happening in this
16-dimensional vial spinner
representation
right and so my question to you would be
what
what concern have you given to the 10 in
spin
or so 10 as the physicists call it which
is well
well the the so-10 the group
as you know uh governs
the uh not the quarks and the leptons
but the gluons
and the and the uh the weak
bosons and the photons so the force
mediating particles
and there are new ones that are that
arise in the bigger theory in the so-10
that mediate things like proton decay
and
generate masses for neutrinos and so
i've very much been following i very
much followed that
question again sir because that is the
45-dimensional representation of spin
10.
and
[Laughter]
the only place okay i mean well i don't
appreciate that because i'm a
non-physicist i get to ask
these things whereas if i was a
professional physicist i'd have to worry
about their consequence
well it's an artificial separation
because to me the uh
the rep the dimension of of the space
so that there's a 10-dimensional
representation there's
a 45-dimensional representation there's
a
uh 16-dimensional representation that
all play important roles
in the theory the ten dimensional
representation actually does
play a role in the theory that's where
the higgs particle lives
well so this is the interesting the fact
that world so 10 s10 is
is really just a label you could call it
g for group
it would still be the same group and
it's represented in different ways
some of which are 10-dimensional some of
which are 45-dimensional some of which
are 16-dimensional
the underlying symmetry is not really
the case
because spin 10 and spin nine are a very
important
transitional period where the first
let's say
one through nine dimensions gets you
through what would be called the
exceptional isomorphisms in bot
periodicity
but above that level the uh
the group has different properties
because it stops acting transitively on
on its the orbits of its spin
representation but let me ask you
another couple of questions
one more question and then i do want to
remind people that number 10 is very
important because
uh frank's next book is fundamentals 10
keys to reality not spin 10.
i'll uh i i promise frank would be off
at the hour eric we'll take one more
question from the audience from you
uh let's make it a little little brisk
all right so the one question i also
would have asked is
i have a feeling that you think that it
might be that some
of the spinless fields that we use
whether the inflaton
whether we're talking about quintessence
whether we're talking about the higgs
field
might be related to each other in a way
that has not
been fully understood is it possible
that any of these fields that we invoke
um to sort of get out of jail for
various problems elsewhere could be the
same like you never see clark kent
and superman in the same place we think
that these are distinct fields but maybe
they're different
maybe they're just maybe they're the
same they they certainly could be the
same
uh and people have explored
i'd say with mixed success
at best the idea that the higgs particle
and
the higgs field and the inflaton are the
same thing
uh i think more likely
is that we'll find a more encompassing
theory
that has all these different particles
as
uh consequences
so that we'll see that they're not
really independent
ideas but they'll be they'll be
unified at the level of concepts not at
the level of identity
very good thank you guys thank you uh
especially to
my guest today frank wilczyk uh who
is uh the author of this book a
beautiful question which is a beautiful
book
uh inside and out beautifully bound
actually and lavishly illustrated with
colorful representations of different
objects including
some spin groups that we just heard
about but i want to also notify people
that we are going to be
live with uh with uh frank wilcheck
in a month to talk about his new book
upcoming book fundamentals
10 keys to reality frank i want to thank
you so much for going into the
impossible i want to ask
the audience to tune in and subscribe to
hear interviews with
barry barrish ray weiss uh fellow
laureates
of uh frank wilcek and also hopefully
we're going to get
cn yang frank yang another frank nobel
laureate and i'll bring on frank
frank i hope i can bring you on if i do
manage to pull that off you
and uh maybe shelly glashow and also jim
simons but i'll keep you posted frank
get back to that would be that would be
extraordinary and uh
you know i promise not to be the uh fly
in the ointment if
if that comes to be i'll do i'll move
heaven and earth to participate i will
do my best
thank you so much we i loved having you
on everybody out there
thank you for going into the impossible
with brian keating i am your fearful
host looking forward to our next episode
together and now
intro outro music from my friend miguel
yeti tears online
thank you frank thanks eric i'll see you
hopefully maybe later tonight
i'm gonna sign off now so bye bye bye
guys
eric how are you my friend look at you
mr big shot podcast
well you missed the beginning i asked
him about imposter syndrome
uh when it came to uh to the nobel prize
as i asked barry barish
last last week when he was on the show
that interview will come out soon i
asked barry did you ever have imposter
syndrome
and he said all the time especially when
he went to go collect this little
medallion and he sat aside the same book
that
this guy's name was signed in just above
and he said i never felt
more of an imposter in my whole life i
asked frank wilcheck what do you think
he said
imposter imposter syndrome uh not since
breakfast
no not since uh he was 12 years old he
took an iq test
as a high schooler in uh queens new york
and it came out
uh phenomenally for him and it's been
all the way
uh for him but he did say that he wished
he had
maybe spent a little bit more time
learning quantum field theory uh which i
found
kind of a kick in the tail because if
he's got problems with quantum field
theory you know
what hope do i have
i think that that's a really interesting
answer because
in large measure quantum field theory is
the only thing that really
underwent a major intellectual
revolution after frank so frank is the
last
person literally the last person to
contribute to the standard model
he he's now 69 in terms of youth
yes the um the thing that happened
after him was the geometrization of
quantum field here
and in some weird way if if you preceded
a paper called the gucci guilty
enhancement you think about the world
one way and if you
follow that paper you think about it a
different way because that was the paper
that introduced geometric language to
the physicists
and then you know so many of like
whitman's insights frank belongs to an
earlier world ed
is born later the same year and he's on
the other side of that divide so that
will check to whitten is the divide in
my opinion
as to where we become smarter and dumber
at the same time
but i also mentioned the quote from t.s
eliot where he said no one's ever done
anything after he won the nobel prize
it's like a ticket to their funeral
and it couldn't be farther from the
truth in the case of frank wilcheck who
was 22 years old when he came up with
asymptotic freedom with uh david
politzer and david gross had to endure
didn't win the prize for a long time
34 years i mean can you imagine that or
30 31 years
i couldn't ima i said how was that
feeling and it basically sounded like he
was excruciating by the way i think
we're
inventing a new genre right now eric
podcast
debriefing in the middle of an active
live podcast stream on youtube but i
love it it's it's
i'm here to break barriers and go into
the impossible
well there you go i mean i also thought
that his uh his responses
this this throwaway comment that he made
about
spin 10 and the regular spinners on
space time
you know we hit pay dirt because what
you're hearing about is that this is a
private research
program and that people are embarrassed
to air
their sort of private thoughts this was
a daring thing to do
in the culture but it shouldn't be
daring at all i mean
how important that idea i believe is
going to
turn out to be one of the most important
ideas ever yeah so i want people to tune
in
uh tomorrow hopefully in person we'll
have eric weinstein with a better audio
quality
uh not better video quality you've got
remarkable video
and the audio just needs a little bit of
tweaking but i bought you a present
i got you a present here uh well it's
it's over there it's a microphone eric i
hate to spoil the hanukkah surprise but
i got you a microphone
a real live microphone
there's only two things that people say
about you when you come on my show
uh how handsome you look how much weight
you've lost maybe three things
how you need a better microphone so
we're going to do that and maybe
something about publication but
we're not going to go there that's a
certain spot we're going to talk about
that
in person tomorrow
did you think of your interaction with
frank
oh yeah i think i thought it was i
thought it was marvelous he actually
echoed some things that i've been
thinking about for a long time
and that you know i'm gonna run by you
in person tomorrow
and that has to do with why don't people
test the low energy
uh consequences of their models using
existing data sets so
imagine if i said to you you know i've
got this great theory but it requires an
atom smasher that's twice as big as as
lhc well i could say well i've got this
thing it's
it collides uh two 30 mass solar mass
neutron stars at 99.9997
the speed of light would that interest
you you know does that have any
relevance to your uh
to your theory and and he basically said
yeah those are the kinds of tests that
you want to look at
for consequences low energy and he gave
the example that he published with
lawrence krauss
uh called uh from b modes to quantum
gravity this one some prize
and gravity research in 2014 after bicep
two
but before it was retracted and that was
anticipating
whether or not you could actually say
that gravity is quantized from
low energy phenomena such as a b mode
polarization the kind of which i study
you know one thing i thought was really
cool is is looking at his book is a lot
about color
and light and he goes through these
beautiful examples
of beautiful things in nature there's a
beautiful squid
you know we'll be having that for lunch
when you come tomorrow uh but the uh but
the beautiful things in nature
that uh that isaac newton discovered you
remember he unified
spectral theory color theory was not
thought to be part of physics it was
like
mysticism maybe it happens in the eye
maybe it happened but he showed you have
a prism
and you take a spectrum of the sun and
then you block out the color
green let's just say and then you put it
together with another prism so you do a
summing operation
and out doesn't come white light and
that was a
demonstration that it's not a
physiological property so he unified
within the laws of of physics so to
speak
empirical evidence at low energies which
we'd later discover as frank talks about
in the book
that high energies has a consequence in
uh maxwell's theories
which he basically views maxwell as his
superhero as his avatar in physics and
i can't fault him for that um but uh i
kind of view faraday myself because
faraday would do the experiments
without any mathematical knowledge and
uh and i think the experiment is the key
you know i've told people in the chat
room right now leave a thumbs up if you
have heard a theory of everything lately
and then leave a comment in the comment
section if you have a theory of
everything
uh because it's it's rough comment
section
that's right i know it's gonna be brutal
that's a high bar right
all right well i'll let you go uh thanks
for coming on on tomorrow let's do a
live stream i want to talk about this
new idea a project that i have
to uh act as a weinstein
keating sieve to get to the root of what
it means to
have a working theory of everything
until then well
such an exciting invitation i'll even
come down to san diego what do you think
all right i've got room on the couch
here
we'll both be in the doghouse when my
wife figures out how much time
i've been spending podcasting everybody
out there i love you guys
please just cross things like strangers
on a train we'll both sleep on each
other's couch
everybody thank you so much please
subscribe to the podcast so we can get
more great guests like eric and
and frank wilcheck and next week we're
gonna come run vafa
we're gonna have barry barish we're
gonna have uh carlo rovelli has agreed
to come on
and uh and oprah and uh well oprah's
coming on to give me a new couch
uh everybody will get a couch so for now
signing off your fearful host brian
keating have a great day everybody
bye guys
do
[Music]
you